in this demonstration I'm going to show
you how to configure a writable LDAP
server in the IBM developer portal so
the first step here is to ensure that
your catalog for which you've got your
developer portal for has the portal
delegated user registry configured as
the user registry the next step is to
configure the modules that you need so
two modules the modules you need are
LDAP authentication LDAP servers and
LDAP user and safe the next step is to
configure configuration people LDAP
configuration servers and here I need to
out add them LDAP server configuration
the first section I need to do is the
connection settings tab so choose a
unique machine name
what miss enabled and I want to use open
LDAP alongside the LDAP server that I'm
going to use this is the IP or domain
name of my LDAP server and I know that I
have created my other server using port
389 so that section is completed I now
need to fill in binding method and for
this I need to ensure that I've got the
service account bind enabled and now I
need to configure the n4 non-anonymous
search and in this case it is us so and
then just supplied password for my
server the next section is the LDAP user
to Drupal user relationship in this case
it is o u equals people and my specific
domain name author name attribute email
attribute and the expression they use a
DN all finished I'm now going to add I
so I now have LDAP server configured
added before I go any further I am now
going to test my server from the test
page we don't really need to pretend you
these values in here just click the test
button here and we can see that it using
the settings are given it its binding
successfully and so it's now worth going
on to test
pass and configure the rest of the the
LDAP setup so configuration people LDAP
and now I want to go to three user in
the basic provisioning I need to choose
my LDAP server which is the one that I
configure previously and I need that one
and to check that these two options have
been enabled crate or sync to Drupal
user on successful authentication with
LDAP credentials and cradle think to
Drupal user anytime a Drupal user
account is created or updated also
checking that this is being enabled so
if there's a user account conflict
associate Drupal account with the LDAP
entry also by default the the correct
option here has been selected account
creation settings at admin config people
account settings do not affect LDAP
associated Drupal accounts and
furthermore down here is the perform low
action but email lists of orphaned
accounts and that is selected - so the
defaults for the last few options are
correct now we need to do some of the
mappings this is quite a lengthy process
I'd advise referring to Knowledge Center
for the exact mappings the first thing
I'm going to do though is just save and
by saving that some of my mappings are
automatically configured so just to
recap do the the original settings here
spy selecting your server ensuring that
the right options have been chosen and
then save and so some of the mappings
are already created for you in this case
I just have to configure in another two
settings give a name
and select that to first name and that's
FN to last name and save those I now
have the provision from LDAP to Drupal
mappings completed and now need to fill
in the basic provisioning to l-dub
settings and slave again again ensure
that the LDAP server is selected and I
need to select the create all sync -
LDAP entry options here for my entry
provisioning events and now I have a
large table to configure here so I'm
just going to pause for a moment and
I'll get my 8 mappings created I have my
first full mappings created here and
I've need to map another fall so save
let down again and it's now after I've
done that save has now created another
four entries for me to fill in
in fact I realize I've got just one more
to do so another save and then I'll just
scroll down finish up and the last one
is password use only in fact
have just done wrong one there and just
modify that so that's all my fittings
mappings done and now we've got one last
thing to do which is go to the
authentication tab and in the allowable
authentications I'm only going to allow
LDAP authentication so previously I've
allowed a mixed mode of duple
authentication with whatever provider
but I'm only allowing LDAP
authentication now except for user 1
which is the user I currently am which
is admin and I'm going to also select my
LDAP server and down here save so all
ready to try with my first user so now
I'm logged out and I want to log in as a
new user creation account and my
username is going to be Andre and I am
going to be Andre example.com offered
and finish off with my capture
create new account I am now logged in as
Andre and my organization is called
Andre example now I'm just going to hop
over to my LDAP server and you can see I
already have two users here called Bob
and Mary prior users and if I just
refresh I should now see yes I can now
see my new user Andre and the values are
given previously are added so if I log
out Andre and login
and this is the previous user that is on
this LDAP server so there you have it
writable LDAP is now possible in the
developer portal by use of using the
portal dedicated user registry and by
enabling the correct modules and
configuration in the portal